il est là regardez là je tape je fais
tout bouge et c'est un nouveau
smartphone de one love qui va être
présentée c'est le one shot not alors
c'est vrai que c'est pas de smartphone
que j'aurais attendu en premier sa neige
sur une plage attendait plus le one plus
one plus on respire on est plus sur sa
faim très française le one + 10 points
de plus 10 pro qu'on a déjà vu arriver
sur certaines chaînes anglaises
américaines alors c'est les produits qui
viennent d'un port qui viennent d'asie
ou qu'il arrivera on pense plus tard
dans l'année on verra on sait pas quand
tu as tout de suite one + arrive avec ce
tout nouveau produit le one + noord ce2
alors qu'est ce que veut dire c'est
qu'on va recommencer très rapidement
pour revenir en arrière one plus vous
saviez c'était la marque flagship leader
qui arrivait avec un modèle plus une
déclinaison tu es ensuite ils ont sorti
il ya deux ans deux ans ou trois ans
peut-être deux ans la version nord north
c'est moins cher c'est pour s'attaquer à
un marché plus concurrentiel où il y
avait beaucoup de monde dans ce segment
du milieu de gamme et puis ils ont
décliné la gamme avec la gamme c e ce
pour cor edition et c'est le deuxième
modèle voilà pour recycle un peu
l'histoire donc on va se couvrir tous
les regarder avec vous inspire un test
on va regarder ça rapidement c'est vrai
que je vous le dis ça ce matin qu'il
coûte j'ai noté la 369 euros on sait
qu'on n'est pas dans l'idée du flagship
tueur on n'est pas dans le smartphone ou
avoir la grosse performance mais one
place c'est quand même bien nous
surprendre donc on va regarder ça on va
faire un peu de photos un peu de vidéo
on va checker sarsgaard et hop là on
ouvre déjà un peu bouger donc comme
d'hab sur les kits press one place nous
propose des coques directement wyplosz
de l'autre côté le smartphone bon très
standard mais ça marche ratant des
phares pour l'ouvrir aux règles
générales on prend des ciseaux à ces
trois heures à l'ouvrir aux quais à
oreille sur ce modèle on n'a pas
l'inviter chaîne let her qu'on a sur les
gammes haut de gamme de chez one fleuve
où on a un petit mot de pete là qui est
tout mignon petit coque transparente là
je dois avoir je pense du câble et n'ont
même pas lasser tout les assez rigolo ça
des teams une drôle de tête yoan plaçais
garder ça c'est l'équipe qui nous ont
mis leurs petits dessins que leur petit
nom en dessous trouve ça hyper hyper à
hyper marrant ok ok on a une équipe de
28 personnes voilà voilà voilà l'équipe
de rennes plage vous les présente ok on
va avoir tout ce qui va être je suppose
garantie ici ça roule pas d'autres
câbles à l'intérieur
allez en mes salades dans le smartphone
en lui-même qu'on va regarder on a
ensuite un truc pour tirer là on voit
arriver le fameux câbles rouge de one
voice qu'on connaît très bien avec ici
de l'usb à et de l'usb c'est de l'autre
côté puis un gros bloc de charges alors
regardez sa tête vous intéressé parce
que moi ça m'intéresse si on le voit dès
le départ qu'est ce qui est écrit ici il
ya écrit super vous et non pas vaps
charge alors tous ceux qui ne sont pas
coutumiers de wyplosz qu'ils avaient la
vague charge 325 pas ce qui s'est passé
c'est tu apprennes plus on faisait déjà
partie du même groupe que aux paumés ya
eu un vrai rapprochement stratégique a
très très peu de temps avec un branle
bas de combat et des grandes
modifications en interne est ce qui fait
qu on arrive à voir choses qui sont
vraiment mutualisé donc fini la barbe
charge et bonjour la superbe look de au
pot qui marche très bien au delà de la
marque au delà du côté pour certains
consommateurs qui aimait vraiment la
varde charge et le côté très différent
de wyplosz on a quelque chose qui
fonctionne berger vous l'expliquer au
niveau de la batterie vous allez voir
comment ça fonctionne voilà on a pas
d'écouteurs à l'intérieur parce que je
voulais déjà dit avec les smartphones de
sam sont des constructeurs n'ont plus
l'obligation aujourd'hui à mettre des
écouteurs filière donc à pas d'écouteurs
filaire à l'intérieur mais trucs
intéressants vous avez votre blog de
charge 65 watts voilà alors on va passer
aux smartphones même pour le regarder
alors je le connais déjà un peu parce
que j'ai eu toutes les informations à ce
sujet auprès jolie comme ça a commencé
quelques quel modèle moi quelle couleur
parce qu'alors à l'interné je suis
surpris parce que je le vois en couleurs
plutôt blanche allez me dire ce que vous
en pensez y à côté argent entre argent
et alors que moi dans les infos que j'ai
eu il existait en bleu je peux vous dire
de bêtises ans il existait uniquement en
bleu et en gris alors est ce que c'est
le gris ça ne fait peut-être le grand
ouest avec le gris c'est un côté très
vitry alors pour le coup et regardez on
the un goût ne voyais dedans vous parler
comme ça les yeux dans les yeux au
travers du smartphone là on se voit donc
je sens que pour la photo les miniatures
jeu relativement de marée c'est un
emprunt de mettre le gris à mon avis
qu'il existe donc là vous dis hongrie en
bleu et petites traces de colle sur le
côté c'est pas ouf mais c'est comme ça
alors le module photo plutôt bien on
retrouve l'idée en fait j'ai
l'impression du wan +9 de l'année
dernière module qui est légèrement
regarder un peu en relief son côté
j'aime bien jouer ça c'est joli ce très
joli mais bon voilà ça c'est pour moi
c'est un délit traces de doigts là tout
de suite là c'est ça prend énormément
avait là les traces de doigts ça va être
mortel n'est vraiment mettre une coque
de protection vous en avez là qu'ils
sont sympas chez one plust mais les
liens en bas dans la description aller
jeter un oeil vraiment nabi parce que
sinon vous allez vous arracher les
cheveux que les traces de doigts là
dessus qu'est ce qu'on a ici le bouton
pour venir l'allumer et pour l'éteindre
bouton de volume le tiroir de cartes sim
15 tiroirs de cartes sim il est
intéressant parce que vous avez double
n'a nothing plus carte microsd d'une
extension jusqu'à un terrain comme ça
c'est bien et double nano 5g ok vous
retrouver sur le dessus votre petit
micro pour la réduction de bruit ou
quais et sur le dessous un petit haut
parleur le micro prise jack 3.5 pour
tous les audiophiles et ceux qui veulent
du jazz propose 5 vous l'avez et puis
voilà voilà pour ce smartphone pour la
face extérieure alors maintenant
laissez-moi quelques instants le temps
de l'allumer de le paramétrer et puis on
va aller un peu plus loin au niveau des
explications la petite bête regarder je
voulais configurer je voulais installé
là je voulais paramétrer alors on va
aller dans les paramètres pour que je
vous montre ça déjà comme ça on le voit
vous avez un tout petit mon conte sur le
bas donc là dessus il ya aucun problème
on se rappelle du tarif je n'ai pas pris
part car je suis je devrais les
apprendre par coeur 369 euros à 369
euros un smartphone avec un menton pour
moi c'est pas des conneries ça ne pose
pas de problème vous avez effectivement
des petits bourgs sur le côté ou si ça
fonctionne petit bord là la caméra qui
situe ici sur le côté ok why not on va
regarder ça vous avez un petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales sous l'écran pour
déverrouiller très facilement je pose
mon doigt hop là c'est pas le plus
réactif mais bon il faut de plus 3 169
euros alors ça va ça fonctionne c'est le
petit canon qui a pas de souci là-dessus
que vous dire d'autre à bas ici on va
tourner sur oxygen os 11 basé sur un
android 11 donc l'expérience logiciel a
les bonnes et puis je sais pas si vous
vous êtes coutumier si vous connaissez
que je pense que vous connaissez pas
nécessairement si vous regardez cette
vidéo il ya deux types de personnes y'a
vraiment les personnes qui sont à ses
fans de one place et qui du coup on
regarde cette vidéo je vous comprend un
coucou à vous et je vous aime il y aura
bonnet vous s'est pas fait le petit
bouton rouge hélas si le rocher vous
n'êtes pas abonné d'ailleurs si vous
êtes déjà abonné à actionner la cloche
comme ça vous serez notifié dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça c'est
cool dans tous les cas on actionne la
cloche donc ça c'est plutôt le bon point
donc effectivement les gros fans je sais
pas si vous êtes un fan de one plaît
dites le moi en commentaire peut-être
bien failli et peut-être voulez-vous
dire regardez pas ce que c'est vrai que
c'est une place une très belle
expérience logiciel il ya une communauté
très forte et quelques changements chez
one poste donc c'est vrai que c'est un
peu différent par rapport à ce qu'on a
connu une époque mais néanmoins ça reste
quand même vachement intéressant et très
cool expérience et bien on est ici donc
je voulais dit sur oxygen noël 11 on
peut venir regarder voyager les à
fabriquer une nouvelle version je vais
venir la télécharger tout à l'heure
comme ça hop là j'aurai la dernière
version et puis il ya une deuxième
typologie de personnes qui va notamment
s'intéresser à ce smartphone il a bien
ce sont des personnes qui ne sont pas
nécessairement connaisseuse de wang
place mais qui par contre vont venir s'y
intéresser par recommandations que ça
veut dire que dans votre réseau vous
avez un pote un ami un collègue qui est
un smartphone de one pleuve qu'il aime
tellement qu'il vous en a vanté les
mérites et que vous a dit ben tiens je
vais regarder parce que ça a l'air très
cool mais c'est vrai que quand on est
beaucoup la marque pardon sur la gamme
d'ordre est pas particulièrement sur les
seuils on va plus sur le 9/9 pro et
bientôt le 10 10 pro et pl comme ce sont
des smartphones qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui référencé dans les magasins
ils l'ont été à une époque ils ne sont
plus actuellement et bien c'est pas en
allant vous balader fnac darty boulanger
que vous allez bien les trouver plus
dans les magasins online mais en règle
générale on tombe pas trop par hasard
dessus voilà un peu le principe donc
peut-être connaissez-vous peut-être vous
en train de vous renseigner dites le moi
ça m'intéresse donc voilà l'expérience
logiciels à être très très bonne elle
est très fluide très intéressante il ya
plein d'options de personnalisation qui
sont très cool et aujourd'hui on se
rapproche un petit peu de colère ou est
ce parce que je voulais dit un vrai gros
rapprochement en fait vous avez au pot
et ewan plaisent bien peu se coller aux
peaux et de la mutualisation donc on va
retrouver des choses qu'on connaissait
déjà chez au pot notamment au niveau des
styles d'icônes au niveau de pas mal de
petites choses qui vous rappelleront
facilement colorisme pour l'instant on
n'est pas sûr que leurs os même si in
fine et et à terme on finira avec un col
hors us dans les smartphones de wons à
mon avis c'est comme ça que ça va se
passer ou une plage deviendra une sous
marque de haut pont ça devrait arriver
comme ça qu'est ce qu'une fois en tout
cas arrivé c'est quand même bien ici au
niveau d'oxygène os et qu'on a
aujourd'hui une bonne expérience
attendez je vous montrais affichage en
bihan comment ils nous mettent ça s'est
un peu plus monochrome qu'il boxe
préfère que l'on ait un peu plus de
couleur là c'est quand même assez
monochrome je crois six comédiens le
le module et c'est un peu notre
personnalisation fait de voir où leur
jeu mais bien moins le rouge qu'on avait
avant il y avait un truc un peu plus
ouais c'est un peu mieux avec ce côté
rouge à chaud ça quand même vachement
plus sympa affichage et luminosité
confort des yeux sommeil adaptatif
expérience est quand même bien là dessus
donc si vous voulez regarder améliorer
hop là la couleur idéaux et la rade et
vous avez la fréquence d'actualisation
enfin c'est intéressant parce qu'en fait
ici vous avez un écran de 6,43 pousser
la diago avec un taux d'actualisation de
90 ans mais vous pouvez vous mettre en
90 ans ou alors rester sur du 60 m 90e
ça va être élevé sagna que ça va venir
consommer davantage si vous voulez y
aller un peu plus mollo et gagner en
autonomie vous restez en standard et en
60 hertz ça ira parfaitement bien ici on
est sur un écran qui est certifié hdr 10
plus cool c'est du fluide amoled plus
d'un mollet tu sais quoi c'est de la
molette ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que c'est dû aux led ça veut dire quoi
que lorsque vous le passez en thèmes
sombres et bien tout ce que vous allez
avoir en noir sont des pixels et un donc
ça vient pas consommer à la différence
d'un écran lcd le noir c'est par apx à
l'étape donc on va venir gagner ici au
niveau de l'autonomie de son smartphone
résolution full hd + et un ratio vingt
neuvième enfin bref on est dans l'air du
temps et ici rien de bien surprenant on
à l'avant un corning gorilla glass cinq
ans ça veut dire résistant on n'est pas
sûr derrière génération de corning ici
mais malgré tout ça fait le taf alors
ici on a du haut parleur mono est situé
là ici il ya trajet haut parleurs stéréo
ça sort quand je la fais ça tu en as ce
niveau-là ça fonctionnera très
clairement à ce que je vous conseille si
c'est pas venir l'utiliser avec leopard
on peut l'utiliser si vous l'écoutez un
truc mais dans un lieu où il ya un petit
peu de bruit ça va venir saturé ça vient
dégrader la qualité c'est pas
extraordinaire à faible volume mois
voulu modérée chez vous en étant
tranquille vous pouvez dès aujourd'hui
ni à la maison ça ira bien ce que je
vous conseille vraiment là-dessus c'est
devenir branches et hop là on va sortir
de youtube devenir branché soit 1,15 qui
si elles via la prise jack soit sinon je
me rappellerai les écouteurs en
bluetooth parce que vous avez du
bluetooth 5.2 compatible à ptx à péter x
hd vous avez du lda que vous avez dû à
ac vous avez du sbc vous avez plein de
codecs donc il ya de quoi faire ici et
ça devrait quand même plutôt bien se
passer on va parler de la performance
que ça c'est un sujet qui intéresse en
garde et aux plages comment ça mais
d'être à deux doigts un peu de tous les
côtés ici on trouve ici un processeur
médiathèque c'est un d'e-mails city 9
santé grave et on signe à nomades c'est
un processeur 5 g il ya deux conflits
qui existent au niveau de la ram et nous
y en a une seule en france vous avez
soit 6.8 j drame c'est la lpddr2 4x pour
ceux que ça va intéresser nous c'est la
version 8 gigas de ram sans booster donc
ça c'est vachement bien pour la france
et vous avez une seule config au niveau
du stockage et du 128 giga de stockage
en mai fais 2.2 qu'on peut monter
jusqu'à 1 tera grâce à une carte micro
sd assez bien se dit man city 9 sont il
sera très bien pour faire tourner plein
de jeux duplex store vous avez
suffisamment performance pour que ce
soit fluide en une config qui est
intéressante et on voit en plus ici coin
de pelouse s'adresse à une cible plutôt
jeunes qui va venir jouer à des jeux
pour du gaming pour des réseaux sociaux
pour du multimédia pour me regarder des
films et des séries donc avec ce
processeur là vous avez quelque chose
qui va très bien et après il ya un truc
qui est vachement intéressant c'est
toute la partie autonomie on a ici une
batterie de 4500 milliampères heures
4500 milan perd heures à faire le tard
pour vous emmener une journée et demi à
peu près en moyenne mais le truc qui est
rassurant c'est que vous avez de la
superbe look oui et chez au pot envie
d'y être c'est une techno de au pot ils
sont malins qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
vous font une techno avec une batterie
by cellulaire c'est à dire que dans
votre smartphone vous avez pas une seule
grosse batterie de 4500 millions terreur
non vous avez en réalité deux batteries
de
2250 millan pérol qu'est ce qui va se
passer bien si c'est la recharge faible
tension tu vas venir charger vos deux
batteries en même temps comme ça et vite
devenir stressé la batterie et de
l'endommager au long cours et puis de
toute façon pas ce que vous voulez vous
changer avec un bloc de charge 65 watts
vous avez un pic dès le départ 65 fois
et après sa descente donc ça va venir
recharger plus doucement vos de
batteries pour les emmener le plus loin
possible sans aucun problème donc ça
veut dire un truc ça ça veut dire que en
fait on se pose plus trop aujourd'hui la
question avec des blocs de charges comme
ça de l'autonomie son smartphone hors
bien évidemment veut pas une autonomie
d'une demi journée mais si par exemple
vous jouez beaucoup êtes un vieillard un
hardcore gamer sur smartphone milieu de
gamme eh bien vous voulez venir
recharger aller il tiendra paie pas la
fin de la journée si vous passez
beaucoup de temps à jouer dessus et bien
qu'est ce que vous faites vous prenez
vous le branchez en un quart d'heure
vous êtes reparti pour une journée de
jeux donc ya aucun problème ça devient
extrêmement rassurant la seule chose
dont vous avez besoin c'est d'abord une
prise électrique pas très loin et ne
jamais oublier votre blog de charge
alors attention parce que c'est quand
même un bloc de charge qui est un peu
gros qui un peu proéminent donc il faut
le mettre dans son sac il faut pas
l'oublier mais sinon vous posez pas la
question d'autonomie après sur un usage
modéré un usage moyen une journée et
demie on l'aurait alors voilà ça c'est
vraiment un truc à venir savoie après
impôts qui est intéressant c'est toute
la partie photo qu'on va venir retrouver
ici on est sur un smartphone milieu de
gamme donc on va pas s'attendre à voir
des photos d'un conte à trois capteurs
en réalité vous allez avoir un seul vrai
capteurs qui va être intéressant bon il
y en a deux qui sont je pense bon un
vraiment intéressant et on se regarde
une fois de plus que résultat des photos
dans quelques instants le tout premier
ça va être votre capteur principal ça va
être votre grand-angle 6 1 64 mégapixels
tout bref 1.7 alors attention si comme
moi vous avez un petit tremblement
essentiel et bien vous n'avez pas
fiabilisation optique donc les photos
elle risque un peu de bouger et en
condition de nuit ça va pas être ou faut
que c'est pas forcément le smartphone
que je vais venir vous recommander pour
des photos de nuit sauf si vous bougez
pas d'un iota ou encore mieux vous le
mettez sur un pied vous apporte un ultra
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels j'ouvre f
2.2 avec un champ de vision 219 degrés
puis vous arrivez après jour de la macro
et si tout petit planqué j'aime bien les
constructeurs vous dire je vous mets un
troisième objectif c'est de la macro ça
ne sert à rien du tout c'est un capteur
de 2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 et
puis vous avez à l'avant une caméra qui
planque et là elle c'est une 16
mégapixels à f 2.4 et pour venir faire
de la vidéo regardez vous pouvez venir
filmer en 4/4 il vous le marque ici mais
c'est de la 4k 30 vous pouvez venir
filmer en 1080p jusqu en 60 images par
secondes et vous avez du super slow
motion en 720p qui est plutôt
intéressant mais est clairement ce n'est
pas un smartphone qui va être vraiment
dédié pour venir faire de la vidéo on
peut bien faire de la vidéo une fois de
plus ou moins que le résultat dans
quelques instants le fameux mode nuit
bon ok mode portrait on connaîtra ok et
puis après vous avez quelques petits
trucs en plus histoire de venir vous
marrez du panoramique de l'extra hd la
macro convient active est ici le dual
view convient m ici avec une caméra à
l'avant et une caméra à l'arrière en
même temps si vous souhaitez le faire je
sais pas si tout cela est vraiment
intéressant si certaines personnes le
font mais en tout cas on peut venir le
faire garder on peut le mettre en rond
sur le haut on peut le mettre en
rectangle on peut venir inversé comme on
veut donc voilà il ya un côté un peu
rigolo s'ils ont envie de s'amuser denis
à choper des choses en se montrant et en
montrant ce qu'on est en train de filmer
on peut le faire pourquoi pas voilà les
photos que j'ai fait avec mon one +
north ce2 alors vous allez voir dans
l'ensemble ça des photos qui tire un peu
sur le jeune on s'en rend vraiment
compte 1 sur les bâtiments il ya une
ambiance un petit peu jaune en termes de
contraste c'est pas extrêmement
contrastées on n'a pas de très grosse
profondeur mais une fois de plus si on
remet dans son segment de prix vous
allez voir que il photos qu'il fait
elles sont correctes on commence avec le
grand angle et bien évidemment on essaye
ultra-grand-angle le résultat est somme
toute assez correcte une fois de plus on
replace vraiment dans cette gamme de
prix on peut venir nous met un peu mais
on va pas aller trop loin après on a
effectivement un petit lissage va le
voir on va récupérer un peu de bruit par
ci par là donc on va vraiment voilà on
va pas y aller trop trop près néanmoins
je trouve que dans l'ensemble le boulot
et pas trop mal fait au niveau de la
gestion de la lumière mais il ya
vraiment un côté un petit peu trop trop
prononcé sur le jaune regarde l amont
belvédère il est un petit peu jaune mon
ciel est légèrement j'adore tout ce qui
effectivement marronner devient très
joli à paris vous avez des façades
légèrement je ne me rase encore plus
jaune c1 peugeot d'accès le seul truc
petite différence de colorimétrie on
s'en doutera avec lui très longtemps
mais rien de bien surprenant ici
ultra-grand-angle il n'est pas
extraordinaire regardez là sur le côté
là cette partie là il est un petit peu
de mal bon voilà on est sur un
smartphone dans cette gamme de prix donc
rien de bien déconnant ici on peut se
rapprocher un premier on va éviter trop
le faire les hautes lumières seront un
peu moins bonne mais malgré tout il vous
sort un truc qui n'est pas aux rives la
voyez il vient vraiment tirer légèrement
pour venir compenser on le voit sur ce
nuage là là il ya un truc qui marche pas
mais bon est-ce que c'est problématique
une fois de plus je ne suis pas
convaincu c'est pas parfait mais on va
pas avoir les mêmes exigences sur un
smartphone à 300-400 euros que sur un
smartphone à sept cents ou mille euros
donc on va être un peu plus indulgent
est là dessus très grand temps que c'est
sensiblement la même chose on peut venir
ou non un peu mais pas trop à la fin je
vous dirai toujours un peu à peu je vais
te regarder en fait un les photos mais
vous allez voir que la critique
principale que je viendrais à dresser
ici c'est ce côté trop jeunes que l'on
retrouve un peu partout et ses trucs qui
des fois va être un peu un peu relou
mais sinon dans l'ensemble une sort des
images qui sont tus sont plutôt pas mal
assez sympa là c'est pareil d'impôt du
algorithmique on le voit il y avait le
soleil en face il a voulu compenser pour
vous ressortir le panthéon mais on
arrive quand même à le voir et ça c'est
plutôt bien sur l'ultra grand temps que
ce sera un peu plus poussif mais ça fera
le boulot là c'est pareil à la lgo est
venu vous sortir la mairie du 5e
arrondissement alors vous êtes en plein
contre jour toujours un peu trop jaune
mais le boulot est là le boulot est
rendu et sur un smartphone dans cette
gamme de prix on va pas s'attendre non
plus à voir de la magie alors des choses
qui vont être absolument dans la caméra
de celle fille s'en sort pas trop mal il
ya un côté légèrement légèrement essayé
mais vraiment très très très très
légèrement n'est pas extraordinaire mais
elle n'est pas non plus
où vais-je la voyez j'ai bougé a eu un
petit peu de mal au niveau de noyer sur
le côté sur le côté droit de mon visage
qui va être un peu trop exposée et parce
qu'il cherche à venir compenser sur les
zones d'ombré donc assez d'un point de
vue algorithmique et voilà c'est un peu
la limite du truc mais sinon voilà ça
fonctionne je vous emmène ensuite la
nuit alors la nuit vous allez voir que
c'est pas un smartphone qui est fait
pour faire des photos de nuit parce
qu'on n'a pas le stabilisation optique
ont assez des actions uniquement
électronique donc dès que ça bouge un
peu c'est pas parfait parce qu'on va
venir à voir des expositions un peu plus
long pour pouvoir sortir des photos en
conditions de faible luminosité donc à
moins de le poser sur un trépied ou de
ne pas du tout bougé vous allez avoir un
truc qui va pas être extraordinaire si
vous le posez sur un trépied ça devrait
faire le taf ultra grand-angle et pas
dingue ça votre capteur principal on
doit pouvoir faire deux trois petites
choses mais à la main très clairement
c'est pas un smartphone qui était pour
faire des photos en conditions de faible
luminosité
c'est également un smartphone qui a du
wifi sigma forcément on est sur un
smartphone actuel on a du wifi si on a
du nfc pour le paiement dématérialisé on
n'a pas ici de certification ip alors
parce que ça coûte de l'argent et que
clairement ce que je dois faire bonne
place et bien c est tiré les prix un peu
vers le bas pour être extrêmement
compétitive donc pas de certification ip
mais rien de bien surprenant dans cette
gamme de prix et sa smart phones et je
voulais dit qu'ils en version 828 à 369
euros il est en pré commande alors à
l'heure à laquelle joue le présente il
n'est pas encore dispo en précommande me
veil dispo en pré commande à partir du 3
mars prochain et l'ouverture des ventes
globales ça sera le 10 mars est-ce que
ce smartphone est intéressant ce
smartphone est intéressant si vous aimez
l'expérience oxygène os ici de one love
si vous voulez de la recharge rapide sur
un smartphone à 360 euros si vous voulez
un smartphone qui va être orientés
plutôt jeune gaming avec une vraie
caméra qui vous permettra de faire des
photos dignes de ce nom voilà un peu la
promesse qu'ils aient fait voilà un peu
ce qu'on peut réellement venir faire
avec ce smartphone gaming 90 oeuvres de
la fluidité de la navigation les sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme c'est pas le
smartphone le plus révolutionnaire il
vient étendre la gamme de one place en
rajoute un peu plus mettre un jour cette
gamme noord c es qu'il apporte des
nouveautés significatives la réponse est
clairement non esquivé pour autant
intéressant la réponse est oui bien
évidemment je trouve cool alors
attention et je vous le dis je vous le
redis regarder rien que le temps de
tourner cette vidéo les traces de doigts
et bien ont fleuri à l'arrière de mon
smartphone donc penser réellement venir
le protégé du pour éviter les
déconvenues et de deux pour éviter
d'avoir à tout le temps le nettoyer
comme ça parce que y'a rien pire
qu'avoir un smartphone un peu dégueu
dégueu lorsque vous avez du monde autour
de vous c'est pas vous fait si voilà ce
que j'avais à vous dire aujourd'hui sur
ce one + north ce2 s'il vous intéresse
bien évidemment un lien juste en mal la
description il est plutôt cool plutôt
intéressant et c'est un énième
smartphone dans cette gamme de prix mais
c'est la copie de windows avec oxygène
os et ça c'est cool voilà vous embrasse
pour des soins de vous il ya très vite
ciao
[Musique]